we got the story from fortune
fauci says there are five stages of the
coveted pandemic
and we are still in phase one oh no
i don't know what else you want me to
say guys you know that's it he says the
first phase of the pandemic or the truly
pandemic according to fouchy is where
the world is really very negatively
impacted the following four steps are
deceleration control elimination and
finally eradication here are the
characteristics blah blah blah okay so
he's basically saying get ready it's not
going to end he's like everything that
that that
my career is based on is going to be
around for a while just so you know
with the covet pandemic goes away fauci
goes away and he knows it he's you i've
never heard of the guy until this thing
appeared i mean people in the 80s knew
he was i guess yeah well i'm just like i
look at this and it's like
all this says to me is that the
government failed despite all of their
efforts and all of their claims of
certainty that they knew exactly what
they what to do to fix it here we are
and this is just like an advertisement
against government policy to me to see
this guy just saying no this is as far
as we've gotten and despite all of this
you know that we're still stage one it's
been two years and we're still in stage
one it's two weeks give us more power
you can trust it two weeks to slow the
spread but this this there's some good
news here there's some really good news
here because this is dr fauci saying it
the guy flip-flopped it is wrong on
almost everything which means he's
probably wrong about this as well which
means we're probably closer to the end
than than the actual starting point but
before again fauci a lot of invested
interest he's one of the few bureaucrats
that actually makes more money from his
side hustles than he does from his
government job his government job pays
him more than any other bureaucrat in
washington dc so he's making a lot of
money there was recent financial uh
transactions that were released showing
that he has at least 10 million dollars
in assets and this is a man who's been
working for the government almost his
entire life where has those millions of
dollars come from well of course those
are important questions that a lot of
people should be asking he has a lot of
connections to a lot of very powerful
individuals and of course as we know
everything that the united states has
been involved in has been a big business
against the american people but how do
you see this kind of unfolding uh carry
how do you see this coveted landscape
this this dr fauci landscape moving from
this particular moment in time
honestly i i mean it's just my opinion i
thought hillary clinton was going to win
in 2016. so you know take it for what
it's worth but it's being from los
angeles and having spent a lot of the
pandemic there i think it's going to be
very difficult for the federal
government even for state governments
local governments to keep enforcing this
because people are burned out and los
angeles was one of the most compliant
places in the country as far as i could
tell and as policy-wise and just the
people in general but even like at this
point there are people are they can't do
it anymore they're sick of it even
people who got vaccinated and now they
feel that they were misled i don't want
to say lied to because sure the science
changed but there are people who feel
that even though they followed all of
these protocols they followed all the
policies they obeyed they did what they
were told to be good people and still
it hasn't been resolved
i'm telling you los angeles is such a
liberal place
and i left for six weeks in the fall and
i came back and there was way less
compliance like there were people in
stores not wearing masks and nobody said
anything whereas before i left that you
didn't see that that wasn't a thing and
i know that people are burned out
because of what i'm seeing in los
angeles
where it's heavily liberal and people
really had good intentions about
stopping this part of the pandemic and
doing everything they could to end it i
have a friend who got vaccinated and
now he's being told well actually it
doesn't work you have to get another and
he's not doing it because he felt he did
it for the sake of doing his part
stopping the spread bill marshall the
same thing you know took one for the
team and now he's they're not going to
convince him to do it again but the
problem is if you trust the science and
if the official narrative is the
statements from the cdc and all that is
you need to get your booster then who
are you to to to you know challenge the
system if you're doing your part why
would you stop now now i will always
stress
you know get your advice from trusted
medical professionals don't look at me
about it but i will add
my one of my favorite memes is fauci as
vader saying i have altered the science
pray i don't alter it further yeah
dude the point of this is never to
eradicate the virus from the day one it
was to stop the slow the spread in 15
days so that we don't overload the
hospitals end of story let the thing run
its course don't overload the hospitals
that was the plan not this five point
thing where number five is eradication
of the virus this isn't polio
right and it's weird because i i
remember that talking point it was we
have to not overwhelm hospitals and i'm
looking at this just as i'm looking at
this article and it's like you guys have
had two years and you haven't been able
to get hospitals the resources they need
and i'm still supposed to take your
advice and listen do not even advise
commands and just obey your commands
when you couldn't even solve the initial
problem that all this was for and you've
had all this time i think
you know one thing i think i feel like
we should probably mention more though
with all of this is as much as
policy-wise i think opposition's very
clear it's very libertarian
or or even anarchic for you guys
i also think it's important to point out
there's probably really serious
long-term health effects for covet that
aren't even being picked up right now
and so i say this because
you know it's now been several months
for us but i still i still feel a
presence from having coverage i can feel
it in my back from time to time yeah
still here i can tell i'm just immune
have an immunity to it now well i i
think i i think we're all over i think
we're past it but people get scarring in
their lungs and i think
you've got on the left a complete
over hyping of everything panic non-stop
panic you have many on the right who are
just like be done with it we can't you
know and i i would agree more with that
it's like look
i actually i recognize it's really bad i
get it i think we should continue to to
push for scientific breakthroughs on
this stuff i think we should also remind
people
you know i'm i'm concerned about the
long-term health effects of what
covington i eat crappy food i lose my
smell after covid i eat garlic and onion
i regain my smell it's not kovit's fault
obviously it's dietary
the point i'm trying to make is
you know i think it was uh who was it
was it was
somebody tweeted don't underestimate it
it was a conservative we have had in the
show saying like it's really it is
really really bad don't let anyone tell
you otherwise and i think that's
important i still can't taste or smell
really yeah try dosing yourself with
onion and garlic yeah there there's a
bun so but but i'll put it this way i
just don't want to get lost in being
upset about policy right to
make it seem like we would downplay the
like the sickness because right we talk
about how you you're probably you
probably won't be hospitalized you'll
probably get better but there are
long-term effects and i think that's a
fair point to me and i think that's
what's so frustrating for some people at
least like someone like me like i took
it seriously i was considerate of other
people and yet i'm still thrown into
this category of just a crazy q and on
right-wing nazi trump supporter when in
fact like i've never said that kovit
wasn't serious it's not going to be as
serious for some people as others i had
covert of spine it was pretty mild i
lost my sense of smell but other than
that yeah i was really tired and
my fever never went above 99. so like
people have different responses it's not
to say that not that i'm not saying that
everybody is going to be fine but some
people are going to have a terrible time
and it's important to be considerate of
others the opposition is to these
top-down mandates that even if they did
work i wouldn't support them because
they're mandates but add on that they're
not even effective and i think that's
where so much of the frustration comes
from the answer just really quickly is
personal responsibility if you're
vulnerable you should take extra
measures to protect yourself this is why
i always been talking about terrain
therapy early treatment something that
of course you could be doing this should
be a big wake-up call to a lot of people
saying hey i'm going to take my life my
health into my own hands and i'm going
to make sure that i'm the best
healthiest version of myself because
there is something and we never
underplayed it we always took it
seriously we were affected by it and
it's important to understand personal
responsibility solves all of this your
life is in your hands the government
shouldn't be controlling your life
because when they do they make it
usually a lot worse
that's that's really you know all it is
uh i accept the risks if i want to go
bungee jumping i'll go bungee jumping
don't ban if i want to ride my bike if
i'll ride my bike if i want to go out in
the middle of the woods where there's an
open shooting range that's my choice
don't ban it for me and i'll even add
this because i love the response from
these twitter lefties where they're like
should we ban seat belts and i'm like yo
if you want to wear a seat belt wear a
seatbelt if i don't want to wear a
seatbelt don't force me to do it exactly
i prefer to wear a seat belt new
hampshire
new hampshire no seatbelt loss are you
serious
absolutely no helmet laws either live
free or die
it's your choice as an individual the
first thing the free staters do they're
like all in favor of bending seatbelt
laws absolutely
it's like
hallelujah thank goodness that we live
we have a place in america where we have
still some semblance of personal
responsibility in your life
your life being in in your own hands the
funniest thing i saw in new hampshire
though was it was a man a huge muscular
guy no helmet riding a big harley but
with a big mask on which is
there's bugs too but no but hey do your
thing man yeah that's that's his choice
what he wants to do it's it's his
personal responsibility and and i'm not
even going to judge him until he like
gets thrown off his bike and breaks his
skull and then we have to have 15 ems
workers come out and waste hospital
space to heal this dude that could have
worn a helmet
well that's too bad don't don't don't
strain my system because you're not
going to take your system yeah i'm part
of this system we all are don't strain
it because you don't want to take care
of yourself that bothers me i warned you
carrie that he was an authoritarian some
things like
god
live free but i mean if you want to live
free or die and really take that
consequence then that's a difference no
no no i i think it's i think it's fair
to point out uh ian makes a good point
that there are irresponsible people who
don't take care of their themselves they
don't wear helmets they don't eat right
they get sick and then they do clutter
up the plumbing systems the medical
systems there are people who play with
fire and then jam up our fire department
then accidents are getting taken care of
i just don't think the answer is forcing
people to do things in a sort of nanny
state kind of way because there's no
limit to it i mean are you going to
start policing obese people from eating
cheeseburgers because they weigh down
the system and hurt the medical
institutions obviously that's an
incredulous kind of move that the big
state control
psychopaths want to have over your
existence if someone wants to win a
darwin award this might not sound like
the nicest of things let them win the
darwin award
hold on hold on
it's not even about the darwin award
it's about skydiving exactly right
riding a motorcycle even with a helmet
is very dangerous yeah should we just
say you know what motorcycles but the
thing about seat belts is you don't know
what a car accident's like until you get
into one and if you get into one you
better have your seat belt on because
you're going through yes driving cars is
extremely dangerous more people die from
that than a lot of other causes
of death in the united states but are we
going to ban driving well we don't we
buy heroin from kindergarten classes
because we don't want kids to
accidentally get hooked on it you don't
want someone to accidentally we don't
like kids drive
well yeah we do they're six when they're
16 they're still considered kids
technically for sure they're gonna be
driving trucks where's where's the line
and and you know what i automate them
all ian with respect this is a good
point because people need to understand
our lines for what we tolerate
are they they change from person to
person like what's the what should the
drinking age be some people think it
should be 18. i've actually seen a lot
of there's a advocacy group saying it
should be 18 because they're adults and
that by making this three-year gap from
1821 you actually increase the risk of
someone who lives on their own getting
alcohol poisoning and not seeking
treatment
but everybody's got a different idea of
where that appropriate line is so that's
why i always lean more towards get the
government out of it to a certain degree
unless typically when kids are involved
to a certain age like don't deal drugs
to kids but if you're an adult i think
you should be able to imbibe or partake
as you see fit the problem is
when you decide ian this guy should have
to wear a helmet because he's going to
clog up the system if he gets injured
where do we draw the line should we just
be like don't let him ride the
motorcycle dude don't let him get the
cheeseburger yeah look look look no i
don't like i don't like commercials for
sugar for kids that bothers me like
tobacco industries to sell tobacco to
kids but let's let's address the
motorcycle thing right if you think
someone should have to wear a helmet
when they're on their motorcycle why not
just ban motorcycles then you get no
accidents no because i'm not trying to
prevent the accidents i'm trying to
prevent the the clog to the system and
people with helmets on will still break
their legs and arms and could still hurt
get knocked out and get road rash and
we'll still be in the hospitals so my
thing is hey i'll tell you what's easier
uh ian let's get real dark with it at
least if the guy's not wearing a helmet
he won't go to the hospital go to the
morgue yep right oh that so no no but i
don't always work but my point is if
your concern is clogging up the
hospitals you go in a dark place
the solution to the problem you present
isn't what you think it is forcing
someone to wear a helmet actually would
increase the likelihood they'll go to
the hospital
if you want to clear up the system this
is what happens people understand with
ai they'll say something like we want to
create an algorithm that encoura that
creates a system where people won't clog
the hospitals and they'll just be like
okay no seat belts no helmets everyone
dies hospitals are open no we don't want
them right either yeah i'm not i'm not
looking for the world peace where
everyone gets incinerated so it's quite
useful we just have to accept that
people are going to make choices about
their lives the way they want to live
happy and as long as you're not hurting
others or stealing their stuff
what's the history of seat belts it used
to be there were no seat belt laws
wasn't ralph nader a big crusader yeah
well adding seat belt laws i think so it
was um one of the there was a company
who created the three-point seat belt
and then gave it away for free and then
i don't know if this is true so you guys
can factor me but i was told that there
were insurance companies lobbying for
seat belt laws because
it won't change the amount of accidents
but it will reduce the amount they have
to pay out if people are wearing seat
belts so they were very big advocates
for forcing it thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member
all of these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time